[Música]
Ucrania asegurado haber recuperado desde
principios del mes 6.000 kilómetros
cuadrados de territorio controlado por
los rusos así lo afirmó el presidente
ucraniano
sin embargo en que todos los objetivos
de su llamada operación militar especial
serán alcanzados
Escocia despide a la Reina Isabel II hoy
su féretro fue trasladado desde el
Palacio real de Wally worldhouse hasta
la catedral de Saint estará en Capilla
ardiente durante 24 horas antes de ser
trasladado a Londres además el nuevo
monarca del Rey Carlos III se reunió con
el parlamento escocés
en Suecia podría haber un gobierno de
derecha después de ocho años de gobierno
del partido social demócratas los
resultados provisionales de las
elecciones generales del domingo
posicionan por primera vez en la
historia a la extrema derecha de los
demócrados de Suecia como el segundo
partido más votado
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de Francia 24 yo soy María
Clara calle comenzamos en Ucrania porque
el presidente de ese país boludimir
selensky afirmó que sus tropas han
recuperado cerca de 6.000 kilómetros
cuadrados en la región de jarquif y en
el sur desde principios de mes
recordemos que Ucrania lanzó una contra
ofensiva desde el 6 de septiembre para
recuperar el poder en el noreste del
país y también en el sur en la región de
gerson como lo ven en el mapa además los
ucranianos controlan de nuevo la ciudad
Norteña de
ción su logro más importante desde que
expulsaron a los rusos en la región
capital de kiev escuchemos lo que dijo
celensky
Desde los primeros días de septiembre y
hasta hoy nuestros guerreros han
liberado más de 6.000 kilómetros
cuadrados del territorio de Ucrania en
el sur y el este los avances de nuestras
fuerzas continúan
previamente hablamos con layos zasdi a
de relaciones internacionales y estudios
estratégicos de fuerzas terrestres
navales aéreas y espaciales rusas desde
San Juan Puerto Rico nos explicó Por qué
es relevante el éxito del avance
ucraniano
bueno demuestran que ha sido un fracaso
al menos en su objetivo principal que
había sido tratar de copar de invadir en
febrero a todo Ucrania en pocos días eso
pues se vio ya desde los primeros meses
que era imposible y ahora a pesar de los
avances que
Moscú había logrado en el lugars y
indoniers por ejemplo pues hay esta
contrao ofensiva al norte y noreste de
Jacob que ha logrado empujar a los rusos
y parece que los rusos sean agotado no
tienen digamos que la fuerza
digamos que el equipo la motivación la
moral para seguir adelante parece como
que se han empantanado Así que es muy
relevante porque a Ucrania con las
fuerzas occidentales la tecnología el
armamento que occidente le está dando y
almacenamiento también como usar
adecuadamente su equipo están logrando
empujar a los rusos Y probablemente no
se va a quedar allí el objetivo de
Ucrania es liberar todo su territorio
incluyendo la crimea Aunque tome tiempo
pero este está contraofensiva no solo
por Hardcore pero también los avances
Aunque lentos al sur por gerson está
demostrando que Rusia ahora está en una
fase de defensiva habrá que ver si logra
recuperar la una la iniciativa pero da
la impresión que ahora la iniciativa la
tiene Ucrania además la contraofensiva
ucraniana está afectando un poco al
poder político que tiene el presidente
Vladimir Putin al interior de Rusia
algunos sectores están profundizando su
oposición y por ejemplo pidieron al
parlamento Estatal que presente
acusaciones de traición contra Putin
para destituirlo de su cargo la diosa di
nos explicó si tiene o no futuro esta
solicitud
bueno de momento da la impresión que
Putin está firmemente en el poder por el
apoyo de los servicios de inteligencia
de la fcb servicio de seguridad federal
y que podría estar también dominando a
las fuerzas armadas O sea que no habría
posibilidades aparentes de un golpe
contra Putin En ese sentido y son tropas
profesionales los generales que no
estarían al menos de momento no se ve en
Pos de un alzamiento de un golpe pero no
se puede descartar si sigue digamos que
una guerra que el tiempo va en contra de
Putin Mientras más larga sea esta guerra
más va a sufrir su base de poder más va
a sufrir la economía rusa y más derrotas
probablemente va a recibir puede
intentar quizás la tarjeta La baraja del
armas nucleares tácticas podría ser
capaz Pero eso implicará una reacción
por parte de la otan que para que como
mínimo Ucrania tenga los medios
tecnológicos para derrotar
definitivamente a Rusia Y quizá
bombardearla en su territorio en otras
noticias Escocia le da su último adiós a
la Reina Isabel segunda este lunes es el
ataúd de la monarca británica fue
trasladado desde el Palacio real de
House hasta la catedral de sants la
iglesia más importante de edimburgo El
Rey Carlos III lideró el cortejo fúnebre
junto a sus hermanos La princesa Ana el
Duque de York Android y El conde de
wessex Edward durante 24 horas las
personas pueden entrar a la iglesia
antes de que el féretro sea transportado
a Londres Manuel acá no tiene los
detalles el recorrido comenzó en el
Palacio Hollywood House el Rey Carlos
III encabezó la procesión del ataúd de
la Reina Isabel por las calles de
edimburgo en Escocia
acompañado por la reina consorte Camila
y miembros de la familia Real Como la
princesa Ana y Los Príncipes and you
Edwards el cuerpo de la reina llegó a su
primera parada la catedral de Saint Hill
el camino estuvo marcado por la
solemnidad y la emoción de los
espectadores al lado y lado de la
carretera
tengo 47 años toda mi vida escuché sobre
esta increíble mujer no soy de aquí soy
de muy lejos pero para mí no es solo tu
reina es mi reina también
amo a la reina como siempre lo he hecho
estaba muy molesta cuando murió me
enteré en la escuela y muchas personas
de mi edad realmente no aprecian lo
mucho que ha hecho y lo duro que ha
trabajado
en medio de la emoción el ataúd fue
ingresado en la catedral allí
permanecerá durante 24 horas antes de
seguir su peregrinación hasta Londres la
familia real la primera ministra de
Escocia Nicolas torne y la primera
ministra británica entre otros
presenciaron una ceremonia íntima y
suntuosa en la que el negro de los
vestidos de los asistentes contrastó con
las luces del lugar y donde se entonó el
himno nacional
el acto También estuvo lleno de
simbolismo como la corona de Escocia
colocada sobre el ataúd de la reina a
las afueras el ambiente Es diferente las
largas filas de Los Seguidores de la
monarca marcan el panorama de edimburgo
en estas deberán esperar varias horas
para poder entrar a la catedral Allí se
espera que miles de personas desfilen
para darle un último adiós a la monarca
nuestra mirada especial Natalia Ruiz
está en la catedral de Saints en la
capital escocesa ella nos cuenta cómo
decenas de personas llegan para despedir
a la Reina Isabel II
los despojos mortales de Isabel la
segunda reposan aquí en la catedral de
edimburgo Y esta es la ocasión también
para los escoceses de venir a rendir un
último homenaje a su reina de despedirse
de ella muchos han hecho fila desde muy
tempranas horas desde las 6 de la mañana
e incluso durante cinco o seis horas han
estado a lo largo de este día esperando
tener ese momento de Comunión con su
reina de poder por fin decirle adiós Lo
cierto es que Isabel la segunda dejará
tierras escocesas eso será el día de
mañana martes cuando viaje su féretro a
Londres y lo hará en un avión
será un viaje en el cual pues la
princesa Ana estará acompañando ese
féretro y luego será traslado a Londres
y será llevado al palacio de buckingham
y además de estar en Escocia para
acompañar el traslado del ataúd de la
reina El Monarca Carlos III llegó a
edimburgo también para asistir a su
primera sesión del parlamento escocés
como monarca el rey se dirigió a los
diputados asegurando que su madre había
encontrado un refugio y un hogar en
Escocia con él asistió su esposa y reina
consorte Camila ambos fueron recibidos
por la ministra principal de Escocia
Nicola storgen quien después de un
minuto de silencio en el parlamento
inició la moción de condolencias ahora
el rey viajará a Irlanda del Norte y a
gales antes de llegar al funeral de la
Reina Isabel II en Londres
presidentes Primer Ministro líderes de
partidos y miembros del parlamento
escocés
y el pueblo de Escocia comparten conmigo
un profundo Sentimiento de dolor por la
muerte de mi amada madre
a lo largo de todos los años de su
reinado
la reina como tanta generaciones de
nuestra familia antes que ella encontró
en las colinas de esta tierra y en el
corazón de su gente Un refugio y un
hogar
en Suecia podría haber un gobierno de
derecha después de ocho años del partido
socialdemócratas en el poder los
resultados provisionales de las
elecciones generales del domingo
posicionan por primera vez en la
historia al extrema derecha de los
demócratas de Suecia como el segundo
partido más votado además ellos podrían
formar gobierno por sus alianzas con
tres movimientos de la derecha
tradicional la coalición tendría 176 de
los 349 escaños del parlamento sueco
mientras que la coalición de Centro
izquierda tiene 173 pero todavía falta
que lleguen los resultados de la
votación en el extranjero Y de la
anticipada por lo que solo hasta el
miércoles se sabrá el conteo final
Antonio barrios especialista en
conflictos internacionales nos explicó
previamente A qué se debe que por
primera vez la extrema derecha de Suecia
puede hacer parte del gobierno
bueno los partidos de extrema derecha
han existido prácticamente de la década
de los 90s en toda Europa han sido las
diferentes situaciones que ha vivido
cada país europeo que ha hecho que los
partidos de extrema derecha pues ella
hayan logrado escaños importantes a
nivel del parlamento o incluso incluso
algunos han llegado
a ocupar digamos puestos de poder pero
el caso de Suecia es muy interesante
porque a pesar de que desde 2014
los partidos moderados han gobernado en
Suecia pues prácticamente hay una
preocupación a nivel social muy
importante porque los partidos de
extrema derecha en toda Europa y en el
caso de Suecia no es la excepción se han
alimentado con un discurso antimigrante
que ha atendido a crecer en el caso de
Suecia hay una lucha de pandillas Hay un
problema social bastante profundo hay
toda una situación de crisis económica
que Suecia viene enfrentando y que se
agrava con la situación de la guerra en
Ucrania que le permitió la extrema
derecha en este caso poder utilizar ese
discurso para poder ganar pues votos muy
importantes dentro de la dinámica
política que eso decía ha venido
viviendo y que incluso también de alguna
manera se vio este afectada con las
decisiones que recientemente tomó el
gobierno de Magdalena Anderson pues para
para acceder digamos a Suecia en el caso
de ser miembro de la otan Así que han
habido una serie de factores que se han
conjugado perfectamente para que la
extrema derecha en este caso haya
logrado estos votos que en este momento
está obteniendo Perú tiene nuevo
presidente del Congreso el parlamentario
opositor José Williams fue elegido como
dirigente de legislativo en reemplazo de
Lady gamones quien fue destituida el 6
de septiembre ante la presión del
mandatario Pedro castillo y tras la
filtración de audios que la mostraban
discutiendo sobre Cómo usar su posición
para beneficiar a su partido nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
nos amplía
tras un segundo balotaje y con 67 votos
El Congreso de Perú eligió a José
Williams como su nuevo presidente luego
de un escándalo de audios que motivó la
censura de ley de camones de la jefatura
del parlamento Williams es un general
retirado dirigido a las tropas peruanas
durante el conflicto con Ecuador en 1995
y fue uno de los estrategas de la
operación chavín de huántar en 1997 en
la que se rescataron 72 Rehenes de la
residencia japonesa en Lima quienes
estuvieron secuestrados por el
movimiento revolucionario túpac Amaru
por sus acciones distinguidas en el
ejército fue designado en 2006 como jefe
del Comando conjunto de las fuerzas
armadas Eloy político de 70 años
dirigirá al parlamento de este país
hasta el 28 de julio de 2023 tenemos la
responsabilidad de mejorar la imagen del
Congreso Afirma Williams y señaló que
mantendrá una relación de diálogo con el
gobierno del presidente Pedro Castillo
para satisfacer las necesidades de la
población el nuevo jefe del poder
legislativo también Indicó que su
gestión respeta la división de poderes y
defender a la institucionalidad del
Congreso precisamente algunos analistas
sostienen que José Williams brindará el
contrapeso político de las relaciones
entre el congreso y el poder ejecutivo y
en esa línea señalan que Williams podría
convertirse en el próximo presidente de
los peruanos si es que el parlamento
consigue remover el cargo al presidente
Pedro Castillo mediante un proceso de
vacancia presidencial Por lo pronto
congresistas De oposición alistan una
tercera moción de impeachment contra el
mandatario peruano anuncian que en unos
días socializarán el borrador para
conseguir los 87 votos que se necesitan
falleció a los 96 años El fotógrafo
estadounidense William Klein su mayor
legado es un innovador estilo de retrato
que influyó la moda y la fotografía en
1954 incursionó a profundidad como
fotógrafo luego de conocer a Alexander
liberman el director artístico de boca
entonces empezaron sus 10 años de
colaboración con la revista Klein
también fue cineasta con obras dedicadas
a la industria de la moda o la guerra en
Vietnam y su primera vez en el cine fue
en 1956 cuando trabajó al lado del
director italiano Federico fellini en
noches de Gaviria
hasta aquí las noticias sigan con
nosotros
[Música]